Bueno pues ahí tenían ustedes el debate
el primer debate presidencial de los
candidatos en Estados Unidos Joe biden
por el partido demócrata y el presidente
actual mandatario de Estados Unidos
Donald Trump quien está buscando la
reelección para permanecer en la casa
blanca 4 años más e veíamos las imágenes
desde Cleveland Ohio este debate tuvo
lugar en la universidad Case Western en
esa ciudad del estado de Ohio gracias a
la traducción SIM sima de Laura garzón y
de Camilo gonima que estuvieron dando la
traducción simultánea durante esta hora
y media parte del equipo de producción
de France 24 pues vamos a retomar
Entonces el debate con nuestros
invitados eh Con quienes veníamos
discutiendo la previa del debate ahora
ya tenemos Pues todo lo que quedó sobre
la mesa después de este cara a cara
entre los dos candidatos están con
nosotros y usted está sintonizando
apenas la señal de France 24 estamos
conversando con Julio shilling que es
estratega republicano y también está
estuardo Rodríguez estratega demócrata
analista político los dos están con
nosotros y también se van a conectar a
esta conversación nuestras
corresponsales Diana Castañeda en la
ciudad de Washington y mam menz sala en
la ciudad de Nueva York para conocer
algunos algunas impresiones antes de
darle paso a nuestros corresponsales
para hacer un poco de
e para conocer un poco las impresiones
allí en Estados Unidos Quiero conocer la
opinión de los invitados cómo les
pareció el debate las posiciones la
dinámica comienzo con estuardo
Rodríguez Wow este qué pena por Laura y
Camilo los que estaban traduciendo ese
ese ese debate porque viéndolo la manera
que que manejó el debate el presidente
Trump interrumpiendo
insultando mentira tras mentira Qué
difícil tratar de Traducir y más que
todo la idea que esto es la democ gracia
más grande en el mundo y que ha llegado
a este punto qué vergüenza eh lo que
hemos visto esta noche la falta de
respeto de poder de poder manejar un
debate entre dos candidatos que van a
que están intentando liderar el país más
fuerte más potente en el mundo y no
poder hablar de la política y y la el
camino hacia el el éxito para este país
sin interrumpir Y tratar uno al otro
como bueno Donald Trump tratar al biden
como un un colegial en la secundaria eh
amenazando es una vergüenza lo que vimos
esta noche eh yo he manejado y he
trabajado con campañas presidenciales ya
desde lo desde de más más más atrás del
2000 y nunca he visto un debate de esta
de esta forma vimos lo que pasó Donald
Trump con hillary Clinton y eso fue una
vergüenza pero esta noche vimos otro
punto Donald Trump no tiene pare eh Él
sigue hablando de lo que él desea sin
hablar seriamente de lo que tenemos que
hacer para mejorar la situación en este
país y reconocer que más de 200000
americanos han muerto a causa de la
falta de liderazgo de esta
administración Julio shiling en la
ciudad de Miami sus impresiones hora y
media de debate cuáles son sus
conclusiones estoy de acuerdo con que
realmente con lo que dijo
estuardo que es una vergüenza Y también
coincido que yo nunca he visto en mi
vida un espectáculo que parecía un c
Chris Wall Donald Trump estaba
debatiendo con Chris Wallace y Joe bid
estaba ahí de segundo Chris walles lleva
36 años un demócrata
militante y dijo una cantidad de
mentiras grasas primero defendiendo el
el la teoría crítica de raza un O sea
que en efecto promueve la supremacía
negra
alegando O sea si no entienden lo que es
la teoría crítica de raza pues es como
si habar en el chino es esto es un un
extracto del marxismo del colegio de
Frankfurt que aboga en efecto por la
supresión y represión de blancos como
grupo de identidad para promover una
supremacía negra hasta que en x años se
pueda equiparar segundo la protesta de
eh llamó joh B dijo que la protesta en
frente a la casa blanca fue pacífica
intentaron quemar la iglesia de St John
cómo es posible que eh Chris wes Pues no
le pare y le diga no es incierto
seguimos dijo que de las 20 ciudades
que estaban más o menos divididas con
los republicanos Mentira mentira 18 de
esas ciudades con mayores índices de
Crimen y asesinato están en manos de
demócratas punto cuatro quiso equiparar
eh el terrorismo doméstico o Black lives
matter y antifa con grupos marginales de
derecha no se la destrucción que está
haciendo los grupos Black lives matter y
antifa no se puede equiparar sin embargo
él sí lo
hizo el el el ignorar el tema de Hunter
Bible y la corrupción crasa realmente
nos deja saber el favor que le hizo a y
me causa gracia como los demócratas
al presidente por querer abrir la
economía sin embargo biden está diciendo
La recesión que causó el presidente por
cerrar la economía o sea cómo esta
contradicción en términos y
contradicción moral un moderador no lo
dice muy sencillo Porque el moderador es
un demócrata y realmente estaba ahí para
salvar a El señor biden Julio ahorita
vamos a a retomar algunos de los puntos
que usted tocó en en este en este primer
panorama de su opinión sobre el debate
Quiero conocer entonces eh impresiones
de lo que se ha vivido a lo largo de
esta noche en Washington con Diana
Castañeda nuestra corresponsal allí en
la capital de Estados Unidos eh primeras
impresiones Diana de lo que nos deja e
este debate eh Ya lo veíamos
confrontación de lado y lado insultos
críticas señalamientos mentiras ya
saldrán las empresas que hacen fact
checking a deleitarse a ver qué fue los
cierto o no que dijeron los candidatos a
lo largo de esta noche impresiones
Diana así es y Pues básicamente lo que
vimos fue eh un espacio en este primer
debate más dado para los insultos y
ataques que para un debate sobre las
ideas y propuestas que cada uno de los
dos candidatos presidenciales tiene para
poder ganar estas elecciones y vimos
también como los temas centrales se
enfocaron en algunos de los escándalos
los eh en los que se ha visto
recientemente envuelto el presidente
como fue el escándalo relacionado a la
publicación eh del New York Times sobre
los impuestos del presidente Donald
Trump al igual que eh la publicación eh
frente a la cual el presidente aseguraba
en un libro en una entrevista para un
libro de que conocía con anticipación de
la gravedad que eh significaba covid-19
y no tomó las medidas de manera
anticipada como lo calificaba biden
también la presión del mandatario para
que eh se elija se nomine y también se
apruebe digamos esta nominación de la
candidata e conservadora para ser
miembro de la eh del tribunal supremo al
interior del senado Así que digamos que
estos fueron los principales temas en
los cuales se centró este debate pero
también por el lado eh del presidente
Donald Trump se vieron ataques hacia eh
biden asegurando que lleva más de cuatro
décadas eh trabajando para el partido
demócrata y no ha eh dado resultados
digamos eh su trabajo también se basó en
ataques personales hacia su familia en
específico a su hijo calificándolo de
socialista
eh se vieron varios insultos Como por
ejemplo mentiroso el peor presidente de
los Estados Unidos y realmente moderador
tuvo eh varios momentos difíciles para
poder eh controlar tanto el tiempo y
también tratar de que los dos eh
respondieran los dos candidatos a las
preguntas otro de los eh temas que
digamos eh se abordaron pero muy poco
pues eran los temas más importantes de
digamos a los que están poniendo
atención los votantes y tienen que ver
con el plan de de economía con el plan
de recuperación El plan para abordar
también el calentamiento global que los
dos estaban presentando otro de los
temas centrales fue eh la justicia
racial y la reforma a los departamentos
de policía Así que este es eh digamos
uno de los primeros encuentros que vemos
entre los dos mandatarios tan esperad
por los votantes para conocer más de sus
plataformas y en los cuales Pues los dos
trataban de ganar eh mayor digámoslo eh
aceptación entre los votantes sobre todo
el presidente Donald Trump que tiene una
diferencia eh digamos en las encuestas
recientes de casi seis puntos que le
lleva en cabeza biden y esta era la
oportunidad de digamos tratar de de
ganar esta atención de los votantes Así
que este es el primer encuentro quedan
dos más y y lo que veremos más adelante
será el encuentro ahora entre eh la
candidata a la vicepresidencia cala
Harris y también el candidato eh
republicano en su
fórmula vicepresidencial pens quien se
enfrentarán en la universidad de Uta
para también tratar de llamar la
atención de los votantes de esta área
remota de los Estados Unidos así que
definitivamente Eh pues ha sido un
primer encuentro que como lo mencionaban
nuestros analistas eh Pues deja mucho
que desear frente al debate de ideas
como tal Sí deja mucho que desear y nos
quedamos esperando las ideas las
propuestas y y pues pese a las
diferencias que había en torno a estos
temas Pues nos quedamos con una
confrontación que no fue clar ente la
más sana porque hubo muchos insultos y
ataques de lado y lado incluso hasta eh
temas familiares salieron a relucir a lo
largo de este debate Ya lo vamos a
comentar quiero conversar ahora con
mamen sala ella es nuestra corresponsal
en la ciudad de Nueva York mamen ya
Diana nos hacía como un resumen general
de lo de lo que vimos esta noche
impresiones sobre este debate eh que
como ya lo dijimos pocas ideas muchos
insultos e y un moderador que en algunos
momentos eh sentimos Incluso se le ha
criticado mucho ya en las redes sociales
sobre el manejo que le dio a este debate
presidencial el
primero Sí muy buenas noches Santiago
Pues yo creo que el gran perdedor de
esta noche desgraciadamente ha sido los
votantes porque ha sido imposible
entender con Claridad a los los puntos y
los planes que presenta cada candidato
si Gan las elecciones el próximo 3 de
noviembre Yo creo que cada uno ha
llegado con una estrategia muy clara
Donald Trump ha estado en esa línea en
la que no estoy acostumbrados de crear
hacer un show de de este debate más que
de una información de lo que va a
ofrecer a los votantes de Cara a las
elecciones hemos visto a un Donald Trump
que constantemente interrumpía al
candidato demócrata y hemos visto a un
candidato demócrata que también ha
entrado en ese juego de los insultos no
que como decías pues desde luego no hace
que este debate sea nada sano Joe biden
ha intentado evitar la confrontación
directa con el presidente Donald Trump y
lo hemos visto por ejemplo en pequeños
detalles Porque los gestos también
importan en que ningún momento ha mirado
al presidente simplemente se ha dedicado
Pues a mirar al moderador y a mirar a la
cámara a conectar a tratar de conectar
con esos votantes con esos casi
superando los 80 millones de
espectadores que se preveía que
estuviesen viendo este debate y tenía
muy claro que no iba a entrar en ese
juego Creo que ha habido una oportunidad
que ha perdido Ah de intentar quizá de
entrar más en detalles con esas cuando
ha salido la pregunta acerca de los los
impuestos que justo hemos conocido por
la publicación del New York Times el
domingo Donald Trump ha dicho que él
pagó millones en el 2016 y el 2017
Mientras que el New York Times apunta
según sus investigaciones que no fueron
más de
50 interesante también Las dos últimas
preguntas del moderador que ha intentado
de alguna manera tener una una especie
de compromiso por parte de los
candidatos de cómo actuarán el caso de
que el recuento de votos se complique a
mí me ha llamado la atención que al
final al presidente Donald Trump tampoco
acabado de dejar claro eh Cómo cómo
actuará en caso de que no le convenza
del todo el resultado y tampoco ha
llamado a sus votantes a sus filas a que
guarden la calma En caso de que el 4 de
noviembre los resultados no estén claros
ha sido un debate Pues la verdad
bastante bastante desilusionante porque
al final no hemos podido conocer lo que
ambos candidatos querían poner encima de
la mesa y eso se ha visto también
reflejado en en redes sociales Durante
los 90 minutos que ha durado el debate
Julio estuardo si bien estos debates no
sirven para eh Son muy pocas las
personas que cambian de opinión en
cuanto al voto muchos de los
televidentes ya llegan a estos
escenarios del debate con una opinión
formada y lo que vienen a hacer es
asistir a estos debates en televisión
para conocer las ideas claramente Aquí
no hubo ideas claramente aquí hubo
ataques y y hubo una confrontación de
opiniones y señalamientos Julio por qué
cree que se derivó en esto este debate
donde podían haber expresado ideas que
les puede llevar a ganar uno que otro
voto
eh fíjate Santiago te voy a contestar y
en esto coincido con con algo que dijo
mam Y eso es que la gran el gran
perdedor aquí es la sociedad estad
porque eh realmente al principio eh en
la primera parte del programa les dije
que Eh Pues el el candidato Eh biden
pues no quería que le chequeara el oído
para ver si tenía algo la realidad es
que no le hizo falta porque Chris
Wallace en efecto sirvió de filtro y de
eh un eh propagandista para el partido
democr y y voy a decir mira varios
ejemplos las preguntas que él le hizo a
Donald Trump con respecto a los
impuestos era para
incriminar legalmente Y si fuera corte
poder presentar cargos criminales o sea
eh ejerció Como un abogado en esa
pregunta sin embargo por qué no le quiso
preguntar a a biden sobre el papel que
él jugó en Ucrania y en China que
impactó eh el el tráfico de influencia
porque podía incriminar también a biden
no lo hizo la pregunta que hizo sobre el
cambio climático que le hizo a Trump ya
parte desde un eh entorno ideológico
particular en otras palabras no es
monolítica la opinión científica en
cuanto al cambio climático sin embargo
eh Chris Wallace hace la pregunta desde
la óptica de que sí lo es Entonces él
está que coincide esa perspectiva con eh
la del partido demócrata y la de biden
el tema del la votación y la cosecha de
votos el bolet la boleta ausente es muy
diferente a votar por correo Chris
Wallace lo sabe Sin embargo increpando a
trum
aprovechándose verdad del momento cuando
no es una conspiración no es una teoría
hay prueba por ejemplo de que en Houston
hay una cantidad de boletas de personas
que no son ciudadanas que han sido
descubiertas eh Hay evidencia en
Minnesota donde se está pagando hasta
$800 por voto Esto no es teoría esto es
un hecho en Queens han aparecido boletas
para militares que mandado a las casas a
personas que no son militares esto es un
hecho esto no es un cuento entonces eh
sin embargo el moderador eh partió ya de
nuevo desde una perspectiva de promoción
ideológica que fue el gran escudo que
necesitó
Joe biden y básicamente el presidente
durante todo el evento y podemos
discutir porque coincido en el análisis
de que realmente de política y de qué se
va a hacer No no se habló pero el gran
culpable de que este un fiasco fue el
moderador Chris Wall que en otros años
tpicamente hay más de un mod hay muchos
formatos que tienen varios precisamente
para equilibrar y no ir que un individuo
sea el rey filósofo el que imparte la la
el que tiene la última palabra el
monopolio de la verdad estuardo le
parece a usted que de entrada este
debate tenía entonces las cargas
desequilibradas por parte del moderador
Chris wallas que es un reconocido
presentador periodista de la cadena Fox
New que era la encargada de organizar
este debate la noche de
hoy creo que Chris Wallace hubiera sido
este cualquier otro corresponsal de otro
canal de noticiero CNN msnbc no importa
lo importante es que empezamos con Fox
el canal favorito de President
Trump Nadie puede con Donald Trump como
moderador porque Donald Trump no respeta
a nadie Y eso lo vimos de nuevo esta
noche lo vimos Hace 4 años y lo vimos de
nuevo Lo que están viendo los
estadounidenses que van a votar es un
presidente que prometió mucho Hace 4
años y ha dado poco
resultado las elecciones se
aproximan y esta noche el presidente
Trump tuvo oportunidad de hablar de la
política cuáles son sus
ideas él decidió insultar a biden
atacarle a biden con teorías y otros
cuentos que no se han comprobado no
importa cuánto diga Julio que ha pasado
esto en Ucrania y ha pasado esto en
Houston y los votos falsos no importa lo
que diga Julio la realidad los hechos
los hechos no están ahí para demostrar
algún fraude no importa lo que diga
Julio cualquier persona pue Google a
buscar los hechos la realidad y lo van a
ver y no es cierto el cambio climático
es 100% una realidad no importa lo que
diga Julio porque Julio es un títere de
la de la campaña de Donald Trump
hablando más de las mismas mentiras de
Donald Trump esta noche el votante
americano ha visto bien claro que no
cambia la
estrategia é va a ser lo que beneficia a
él y él va a pedir alante que les dé
otros 4 años Estados Unidos va a sufrir
mucho más de lo que hemos sufrido muchos
más van a morir No solo por coronavirus
pero la violencia de los racistas en
este país que él apoya y eso es
realidad Julio Qué dice usted al
respecto Sí mira
eh estuardo tiene derecho a ser un
mequetrefe eh pero el querer mentirle a
la audiencia es inaceptable o sea él
podrá tratar de defenderlo indefensible
pero eh primero Chris Wallace es hace 36
años un demócrata militante eso es
récord público pero el decir que lo de
las boletas de cosecha que todas estas
cosas que yo mencion el decir que lo de
Hunter bite no existe Hagamos una cosa
tengamos un debate vengamos a las
pruebas y si yo pierdo o el que que p El
perdedor da un año de su salario una
causa un momento un momento los dos
Porque porque los dos están Están
pisando y no oigo a ninguno de los dos
les pido por
favor les pido por favor a los dos que
se calmen y guarden la compostura
bienvenid a sus ideas y sus opiniones
pero por favor los insultos no entre
ustedes dos no Admito acá en la mesa del
debate de France 24 que se insulte
ustedes son analistas y bienvenidas sus
ideas y sus comentarios pero con altura
por favor no vamos a caer en el insulto
lo que acabamos de ver hace una hora y
media Entonces por favor bajé monos de
de bajemos un poco los ánimos Y le doy
paso a mi compañera en la ciudad de
Washington Diana Castañeda vamos a
conocer un poco Diana eh Usted ya va ya
muchos años cubriendo la Casa Blanca del
presidente Trump Eh sabe cómo es la
dinámica su discurso eh No sorprende
este tipo de de formas para manejar este
tipo de eventos públicos como como
periodista como ciudadana que está allí
en Estados Unidos este tipo de dinámicas
pues se volvió parte del panorama de la
política
estadounidense Sí así es yo creo que
desde que el presidente Donald Trump
llegó a la casa blanca incluso cuando
estaba haciendo campaña no solamente los
corresponsales que cubrimos Casa Blanca
pero también los medios en general
tuvieron que hacer una transición en la
manera en la cual cubrir al presidente
eh llevando digamos un control más
cercano de Twitter y de las cosas que el
mandatario anunciaba o decía a través de
su cuenta al igual eh que digamos este
tono completamente diferente de discurso
eh del presidente republicano eh Donald
Trump y esto se ha visto reflejado el
día de hoy incluso anterior a este
debate el presidente había tratado en
sus redes sociales eh de atacar al
candidato demócrata Joe biden asegurando
eh que Joe biden Eh no no contaba con la
suficiente capacidad que incluso eh se
sabía Y que era bien conocido que
consumía narcóticos para tener un mejor
comportamiento y desempeño Durante este
debate eh incluso también el abogado
cercano al presidente Donald Trump
Julian aseguró eh que expertos médicos
habían dicho que biden tenía eh demencia
sin tener las suficientes evidencias
frente a este tema así que digamos que
se ha vuelto común Escuchar estos
ataques por parte del presidente pero es
algo también eh que hace parte de esta
profunda División y algo de lo cual Eh
pues hemos visto reflejado en estas
elecciones que ha generado eh que muchos
votantes que se consideraban
conservadores o que son eh republicanos
estén reconsiderando su decisión frente
a lo que serán estas elecciones Porque
además de eso Eh pues se dio una
coyuntura que no ha favorecido al al
presidente Donald Trump en su agenda
económica y es precisamente esta
pandemia que afectó de manera eh igual a
cualquier familia en los Estados Unidos
alrededor del mundo pero eh
principalmente en el país que tiene
digamos el mayor número de casos Así que
este es un tema eh que ha llevado al
presidente digamos a a tener aún más
ataques para poder eh defenderse frente
a Joe biden gracias Diana por estas
impresiones desde la ciudad de
Washington eh Para cerrar esta ronda con
las corresponsales voy ahora con mamen
mamen usted está en Nueva York es un
territorio particular porque tiene
diferentes componentes hay muchísimos
inmigrantes hay una gran comunidad
Latina afrodescendiente y también fue un
estado o sigue siendo uno de los estados
más golpeados por la pandemia del
covid-19 que es un tema digamos
transversal atraviesa todas las esferas
política económica social cultural en
Estados Unidos en este momento que tiene
más de 200,000 personas ya en sus en sus
números de fallecidos cómo está la
percepción allí en cuanto a la propuesta
de Trump como un candidato que busca la
reelección y biden y le hago la pregunta
porque sabemos y ya lo hemos visto aquí
en este debate con los candidatos y con
los analistas la clara polarización que
tiene Estados
Unidos Sí así es Y desde luego el covid
no ha hecho más que aumentarla junto con
todas las protestas que estamos viendo
en el país Este ha sido también otro de
los temas que hemos visto por ejemplo
hoy en el debate no el acercamiento esa
gestión de la pandemia por parte del
presidente Donald Trump que él mismo ha
dicho que la cuestión de la vacuna se
había convertido o mejor dicho los
demócratas habían convertido la cuestión
de la vacuna en un tema meramente
político cuando al final fue el mismo
presidente quien dijo que la vacuna
estaría l insta antes del 1 de noviembre
algo que aquí en Estados Unidos en Nueva
York no que sí que es verdad que es un
estado más demócrata Se recibió Pues con
cierto escepticismo porque al final las
autoridades sanitarias del país
continúan insistiendo en que eso es
prácticamente imposible Ya no solamente
porque esté lista sino porque sea
posible distribuirla en todo el país
Entonces desde luego Este ha sido un
punto Ah del debate que ha mostrado una
vez más pues la situación en la que nos
encontramos y ha sido un reflejo Pues
eso mismo no de lo que dices de esa
polarización que se ve reflejada también
en las urnas en estos momentos además a
la mayoría de los ciudadanos tienen más
o menos Claro Quiénes vanas quién va a
ser su candidato eh la verdad es que
estos debates llegan en un momento en el
que tan solo hay un 10% de la población
estadounidense indecisa acerca de cuál
va a ser el candidato que elegirá y no
sé yo si este debate va a ayudarles a
aclararse pero desde luego cómo gestione
Donald Trump a el tema del covid-19 Cómo
se sucedan los próximos debates y sobre
todo si en esos debates eh ambos
candidatos son capaces de poner encima
de la mesa Cuáles van a ser sus
soluciones para los problemas que
importan al pueblo estadounidense que al
final son pues violencias protestas
seguridad eh economía eh infectados de
de covid-19 pues entonces quizá sí que
sea más fácil poder poderse decidir por
uno u otro candidato Eso lo veremos el
15 de octubre mamen en la ciudad de
Miami cuando los dos candidatos vuelvan
a ponerse cara a cara para debatir sobre
sus propuestas sobre sus ideas y sus
opiniones en torno a los temas que
aquejan en este momento a Estados Unidos
que como ya lo decíamos es el país con
la mayor cantidad de personas eh
contagiadas con covid-19 según cifras de
la universidad Johns Hopkins le Quiero
agradecer entonces a Diana Castañeda y a
mam men salala desde la ciudad de
Washington y desde la ciudad de Nueva
York por estas impresiones y este
análisis y las perspectivas que nos dan
de este primer debate presidencial
Gracias ellas seguramente estarán el día
de mañana llevando el análisis por
supuesto en los informativos de France
24 a lo a lo largo de nuestra jornada
retomamos Entonces el debate con
nuestros invitados eh Para las personas
que se están conectando a la señal de
France 24 estamos en vivo analizando con
Julio shilling y estuardo
Rodríguez los pormenores de esta hora y
media de debate presidencial en Estados
Unidos y estábamos hablando de los
diferentes temas que tocaron los
candidatos y que trataron de desarrollar
sin muchas ideas la verdad como ya lo
decíamos el punto clave aquí fue que e
hubo una dinámica de debate bastante
particular bastante extraña porque no
hubo mucho debate de ideas Pero sí
muchas acusaciones retomo entonces la
conversación con estuardo en para hablar
de el tema de la pandemia del covid-19
que es ya lo decía cuando está hablando
con mamen es un tema transversal es la
coyuntura principal que está viviendo
Estados Unidos en este momento
discrepancias obviamente como
esperábamos en este tipo de
enfrentamientos Pero qué Proponen los
demócratas entonces entonces para hacer
contrapeso a la situación que se está
generando porque desde los demócratas
han señalado han criticado han acusado
al presidente y Cuáles pueden ser
entonces las salidas a la
situación eh en la solución que han
ofrecido los demócratas siempre ha sido
muy básico el liderazgo republicano por
alguna razón causó el tema de la las
máscaras ser algo
partidista en cualquier otra en
cualquier otro momento de nuestra
historia seguro no hubiera sido
partidista ponerte una máscara algo
sencillo pero presidente Trump no no
quiso apoyar algo así sin embargo quería
abrir todos los negocios y los colegios
y a la misma vez negar a las a las
familias a los trabajadores eh el
respaldo de de las protecciones que
pueden proveer una máscara algo muy
sencillo el partido demócrata también ha
dicho Tenemos que tener un plan el
presidente Trump ha decidió desde
temprano enfocarse en quién culpar y no
enfocarse en un en un plan nacional sino
decidió todo lo contrario decidió que
cada estado decida por sí mismo qué es
lo que van a hacer pero sin un plan
nacional Entonces no pueden de esa
manera coordinar si alguien viaja de
Nueva York a California o de Ohio a
Texas no podemos coordinar Entonces el
caos que dejó el presidente Trump causó
más de 200000 americanos sí morir de
este desastre Entonces el el el plan de
los demócratas es trabajar conjunto
Buscar un plan que ayuda a todos a la
misma vez aunque cada quien vive en una
situación diferente nosotros no nos no
nos queremos quedar en nuestras casas
queremos poder viajar o o ir de un lado
para otro y si estamos viajando no
podemos confiar que un estado tiene otro
plan que que el estado de donde vi de
dónde vinimos Entonces eso es lo que
hace falta en este en esta
administración y biden y y el liderazgo
demócrata promete ayudar a los negocios
a los empresarios darle respaldo
económico y un plan para que se cuide
para que se protejan y que para y y para
que puedan abrir sus sus sus tiendas de
nuevo sus negocios Julio el presidente
Trump ya lo decíamos ha sido criticado
varias veces por la forma en como ha
manejado la pandemia pero es que la
pandemia tomó por sorpresa a todos los
gobiernos y a los sistemas de salud de
todos los países y no había un manual ni
un referente que dijera Cuáles podían
ser los pasos a seguir y es entendible
que muchos gobiernos hayan se hayan
demorado en tomar decisiones o hayan
tenido que esperar ciertas condiciones
para poder garantizarle salud y
bienestar a los ciudadanos cree usted
que el presidente Trump falló en el
inicio de esta estrategia se demoró en
tomar decisiones H restándole
importancia a lo que era esta pandemia a
escala
mundial absolutamente no pero mira eh
para para realmente apreciar eh Y dar
una respuesta
eh que que tenga que ver con con las
acusaciones que se le están haciendo eh
apelo al sentido común eh de los oyentes
eh Porque por un lado hemos hemos oído
de el el el señor del partido demócrata
estuardo creo que se llama eh hablando
de
eh la recesión que Trump causó la
recesión En otras palabras está
criticando que cerró la
economía verdad Entonces por otro lado
está la crítica de que la quiere abrir
eh o sea es una contradicción en
términos una contradicción
moral
extraordinaria el el culpar al
presidente o sea esto se contagia
persona persona no verdad Estamos de
acuerdo con eso cerró los vuelos de el
lugar donde estaba viniendo el
mal por dos meses el partido demócrata
criticó abrió audiencia para investigar
Por qué la administración Trump había
cerrado los vuelos primero de China y
después de Europa entonces y tomaron una
una misión activa de inducir las
personas hacer lo contrario a ir y
abrazar a un chino ir al barrio chino ir
abrazarse todo tener una fiesta Cuando
esta administración cerró los vuelos por
el peligro de contagio fue esta
administración el que recomendó el
cierre de la economía Entonces ahora
resulta que esa recesión que sabemos que
fue forzada para darle el contagio Ah
entonces eso la culpa es de Trump pero
no lo van entonces culpa no le van a dar
el crédito por las vidas que salvó Mira
es inexcusable porque también estamos
viendo y esto lo he visto de varias
personas que
eh andan por ahí o sea lad de analistas
del partido demócrata sirviendo de
apología China Comunista o sea china
sabía totalmente las ramificaciones de
contagio Taiwán lo avisó y se lo dijo a
la Organización Mundial de salud china
no ofreció ningún tipo de cooperación
Entonces esto es peligrosísimo Y hay
que ofrecer obligar a que se rinda cuas
con quien tiene eh la culpa Pero cuando
vemos la estrategia entonces pues decir
que hay que aplicar una política
nacional por si no lo saben Este es un
sistema federal y hay estados que casi
no ha habido contagio Entonces no puedes
Entonces por un lado critican a Trump
que cerró la economía Pero por otro lado
parecen recomendar una respuesta
autoritaria de cerrar totalmente el país
esta incoherencia estamos escuchando es
típico del partido demócrata porque al
final del día lo único que quieren es
salir cuando hay la protesta ahí sí el
contagio no hay problema o sea el el el
el el el el tema del coronavirus no
tiene ningún o sea es tan inteligente
que no se transmite en las protestas que
los demócratas aprueban sin embargo para
ir un velorio para ir a una iglesia para
tener una reunión a favor de un
candidato republicano Ah no no ahí sí se
va a pegar pero no en las protesta
porque yo no he escuchado eh ningún
demócrata responsable decir condenar eso
y bien Se podría prohibir Porque si se
prohíbe ir a una iglesia si se prohíbe
tener determinadas reuniones se pueden
prohibir
manifestaciones basado en el tema a la
salubridad pública pero no lo hacen
porque nuevo Hay una selección en cuanto
al contagio que este virus pue producir
la opinión de Julio shiling nuestro
analista invitado aquí en este análisis
del debate
presidencial en Estados Unidos Ya vamos
llegando al último tramo de este
programa especial para cerrar el
análisis quiero que hablemos de lo que
viene a continuación el 7 de octubre
está el debate de vicepresidentes es
moderado por usa today y allí estarán
Mike pence y camara Harris qué escenario
podemos ver en este debate
vicepresidencial de Cara a estas
elecciones Julio por favor pero puntual
para poderle llegar a las conclusiones
con tiempo para que ustedes puedan hacer
conclusiones robustas en otros eh
debates del el pasado tanto presidencial
como vicepresidencial ha habido más de
una persona eso es fundamental y
realmente no se puede tener una persona
militante de un partido para que sea el
árbitro y el que haga las preguntas
porque sin lugar a duda el terreno no es
correcto Ojalá que en el debate
vicepresidencial pues se tenga una
comitiva que pueda eh presentar incluso
aceptar preguntas eh de una manera eh al
azar del público es mucho más Dinámico
pero no el circo que vimos hoy por Chris
Wallace y ojalá se respeten la palabra Y
dejen que por lo menos desarrolle una
idea en alguna respuesta los candidatos
porque ninguno de los dos dejó terminar
al otro y tampoco se trataron en los
mejores términos estuardo su opinión qué
podemos esperar para el 7 de de
octubre bueno camela Harris ha trabajado
para los americanos de California y por
todo el país ahora como senadora también
abogando para los derechos de de todos
eh derechos civiles derechos humanos Ah
y creo que va a llegar a ese debate con
un plan un plan para el futuro del país
eh dándole un poco de crédito al Vice
President pence al vicepresidente él es
un político también de carrera de
profesión eh maneja su política una
forma más respetuosa que Donald Trump
Que obviamente no respeta nada eh yo
creo que va a ser un debate un poco más
tradicional se va a hablar se va a poder
hablar más de de las ideas por lo por lo
menos eso es lo que espero pero yo creo
que también es importante ver de que el
el vicepresidente pence siempre ha
manejado un papel más callado más en la
sombra de Donald Trump él siempre ha
jugado ese papel de El papá que está
mirando todo de lejos que maneja todas
las ideas un poco más tranquilo que que
el hijo Donald Trump que hoy vimos
también el hijo como actúa cuando se le
acusa de de las realidades de su
administración Es muy posible que vamos
a ver un debate que va a presentar
buenas ideas pero pence siempre va a ser
estar en la sombra y tenemos que
reconocer que un líder un verdadero
líder es alguien que frenta a los
problemas con planes soluciones y no se
enfoca tanto en A quién culpar como
escuchamos acá Julio más se preocupa en
la China y los
culpables las ideas y las soluciones
estuardo rápidamente le pareció a usted
que Joe biden se dejó a arrinconar en
este debate de
hoy Mira definitivamente yo creo que el
Trump es Trump y no va a permitir que
las reglas tradicionales le controlen o
le dejen a él sin respuesta el
vicepresidente biden manejó su su debate
esta noche como un político tradicional
permitiendo y no queriendo enfrentarse
tanto ya la mitad hacia el final ya se
dejó y empezó a a interrumpirle igual a
Donald Trump para No dejarse pero al fin
y al cabo yo creo que el debate no
representó la democracia como nosotros
nacidos acá presidencial debates
presidenciales no se manejó de una forma
respetuosa y eso eso fue liderado por
Donald Trump julio y le parece a usted
que el presidente Donald Trump
definitivamente acaparó el debate se le
fue la mano en la agresividad no
agresividad en en el tono utilizado sino
en en interferir en ser contestatario
del moderador en interrumpir tanto al
otro candidato como al mismo moderador
del
debate el problema Santiago
eh realmente estaba en que
las preguntas y el el el el el formato
que utilizó el moderador Estaba
totalmente prejuiciado eh a favor Julio
pero volvemos entonces a que usted me da
el mismo argumento de siempre lo estoy
preguntando por el presidente Donald
Trump su forma de actuar durante el
debate Cómo la califica usted porque
interrumpió todo el tiempo si se salió
de quiso por supuesto ante la gran
injusticia de un moderador partidista
que más bien parecía o sea el El Vocero
del partido demócrata haciéndole las
preguntas a su candidato o sea yo creo
que Trump entendibles eh en determinados
momento podía haber perdido el estribo
ante realmente el gran descaro de tener
un moderador disfrazado de moderador
cuando estaba ejerciendo un
partidismo totalmente prejuiciado para
defender y favorecer a tropa haciéndole
preguntas cargadas con ya demostrando
una visión ideológica si usted no no ha
explicado ese punto ya en reiteradas
ocasiones a lo a lo largo del debate
para el cierre Julio Quiero preguntarle
importante 15 de octubre debate en la
ciudad de Miami un punto importante para
el voto latino un punto importante
también para el voto
afrodescendiente después de lo que vimos
hoy qué podemos esperar en ese debate
ese segundo debate presidencial en Miami
que es además eh una ciudad de Florida
que es un estado crítico en las
elecciones primero le eh te invito a ti
Santiago y a France 24 al equipo que
vengan a Miami y que hagamos el programa
aquí en Miami sería pues magnífico la si
la pandemia nos lo permitiera podríamos
ir
Julio la pasaríamos bien eh el la
Florida es el cuarto estado de la nación
y realmente se ha convertido en un un
estado refugio para no solo eh
latinoamericanos que huyen de tiranías
sino tamb también incluso norteños
personas que están saliendo por diversas
razones de sus estados entonces la
Florida es fundamental eh el voto Más
allá de determinado sector del voto
puertorriqueño en latino en la Florida
es un respaldo sólido para para Trump y
el tema de la seguridad nacional que es
uno de los punto más importante en mi
apreciación del presidente eh
seguramente va a tomar
primacía en ese debate estuardo su
opinión qué podemos esperar entonces
para el 15 de octubre este escenario ya
lo decíamos yo no suelo dar mi opinión
claramente porque no me corresponde pero
Esperamos que haya nivel de debate que
haya por lo menos
ideas no es tiene que ver Ojalá que que
haiga Al fin y al cabo creo que ya
sabemos después de los debates del 2016
y el debate esta noche donal Trump Sigue
los reglamentos no sigue la eh el
respeto que debe tener un debate
presidencial el mismo vicepresidente Joe
biden dijo esta noche no puede ser que
esto sea un debate presidencial hasta él
mismo no lo reconoce a través de 40 y
pico años que él ha estado en la
política Así que Esperamos que sea un
debate que se pueda intercambiar las
ideas pero a la misma vez entramos
Sabiendo Quiénes y lo que él ha ha ha
causado en este país las tragedias que
ha dejado Bueno pues ahí tienen ustedes
las opiniones de nuestros analistas
difícil hacer este análisis cuando no
hubo ideas claras a lo largo de este
debate de hora y media entre los dos
candidatos que se disputan la
presidencia la Casa Blanca en Estados
Unidos Joe biden del partido demócrata y
el presidente Donald Trump que intenta
llegar por segunda vez a la casa blanca
y mantenerse en el poder por 4 años años
más le Quiero agradecer entonces a mis
dos invitados por haber estado con
nosotros haber compartido sus puntos de
opinión sus impresiones de este debate a
lo largo de la conversación eh También
gracias a nuestras corresponsales en la
ciudad de Washington y en la ciudad de
Nueva York Diana Castañeda y mazala por
haber estado con nosotros y también
darnos un poco el pulso de lo que se
está viviendo allí en estas dos
importantes ciudades de la costa este de
Estados Unidos y por supuesto al equipo
técnico de France 24 por esta
transmisión que hemos estado en vivo
desde las 7:20 de la noche hora de
Bogotá hasta eh poco más de las 10:20 de
la noche llevándoles a ustedes los
detalles el análisis y todo lo
pertinente sobre este eh debate
presidencial a los dos traductores Laura
garzón y Camilo gonima por habernos
traído la traducción simultánea de los
dos candidatos durante hora y media de
debate ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios todas sus impresiones hay
mucho para cortar sobre este tema lo
puede dejar a través de las redes social
sociales Ya se las decía al principio
@fran 24-piso es @ santiogo los
comentarios numeral eldebate f24 Pueden
seguir comentándonos y el análisis de lo
que sucedió esta noche también lo podrán
tener en la programación de France 24 el
día de mañana en los informativos y con
nuestros invitados y nuestros
corresponsales cada hora usted ya lo
sabe siga con la programación de France
i